No
engineer
Oh
hey guys thanks for watching the video I
hope you enjoyed it my college friend
the portrait art drew it for my birthday
while back
he's currently entered into a youtube
contest called on the rise where the
winner gets featured on the YouTube
homepage I'm going to put the link in
the video description down below the
contest ends this Monday so if you do
vote for him and you post a comment down
below saying I voted for the portrait
art I'm going to choose 10 of those
comments and I'm going to feature them
on my next video and thank each one of
you individually as you guys know I've
been really busy with school recently I
had four final exams last week and I
have five final exams coming up this
next week but I have been reading your
comments and requests and you've given
me a ton of ideas for videos that I'd
like to do soon after I finish my exams
I also wanted to thank you guys so much
for helping me break the hundred
thousand subscriber mark not too long
ago my channel is really everything it
is because of you guys and I really need
to thank you for everything
so thank you again so much and you'll
see me next time